[Music]
you have to put
hoorah come to my family
all because I couldn't love a motherless
child
you are a stock
you might not have my name er my blotter
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got our
first official Game of Thrones Season 8
teaser trailer and an official release
date which is way earlier than I
expected so we got to break it down
there's a new round of that Song of Ice
and Fire book giveaway going on - all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the trailer on the video the
big thing going on here mostly a lot of
imagery I don't know if any of these
scenes actually happened during the
episodes but they will probably visit
the crypts sometime in the first couple
of episodes but obviously most of that
first scene is them arriving like Robert
Baratheon arrived in the pilot episode
there's also another really big Easter
egg in here for the pilot episode when
Robert Baratheon and Ned Stark were
walking through the crypts to go to
Liana's statue so if you don't remember
they're really mirroring the long walk
promo that we got last year it was sort
of like the first big teaser with John
Daenerys and Cersei each walking to
their Thrones but obviously this is
focusing mostly on the Starks at
Winterfell because that's what we're
gonna be when the season picks up and
there's a lot of heavy-handed
foreshadowing about them dealing with
John's Targaryen heritage in what his
internal struggle is going to be over
his true identity am i a Targaryen am I
a stark of Winterfell
so John walks past his mother Lyanna
stark in the feather floats down it's a
tropical bird feather the big easter egg
is is this is the feather that Robert
Baratheon brought to her tomb when he
arrived and they went down to visit
there was the whole reason for them
going to the crypts it was actually kind
of a funny scene when you think about it
in retrospect because they arrived had
the formal introduction and then he
basically told Cersei to screw off
because he was going to the crypts
before he did anything else to visit his
long-lost loved who had died but
remember at this point we didn't know
anything about the truth of Robert's
rebellion in Rhaegar Targaryen and
Lyanna Stark so they're walking through
the crypts and he puts a tropical bird
feather like he's basically leaving
something special for the woman that he
loved
then later Dan and Dave had a special
quote about trying to bring that moment
back bring the feather back they said
the last time we saw the Statue of
Lyanna was in the pilot episode King
Robert Baratheon laid this exotic
tropical bird feather in her hand and we
were preparing for the scene we
with Sansa that the feathers probably
still there people haven't been going
down there and cleaning up much
certainly after Ramsay destroyed
Winterfell
there hasn't been any kind of janitorial
crew going down and vacuuming so they
just thought that it would be a really
cool easter egg for the pilot episode in
that original moment that the feather is
still there all the way since the
beginning of the show and now they're
bringing it back because they're finally
paying off John's Targaryen heritage
that Lyanna Stark is his mother so even
though it's a really cool Easter egg for
the pilot it's actually a much bigger
easter egg for everything that's going
on in general but as John walks past his
mother's monument you hear the Lyanna
stark voiceover promise me you have to
protect him the promise that she
extracted from Ned Stark when he was
born he pauses and turns around like he
hears something as if he's hearing her
through time and space like obviously
bran can do that for real but we don't
know the circumstances of house Samwell
and brand are gonna reveal that
information to him but him turning
around here is Justin foreshadowing him
finding out about his true heritage
Santa walks past Catelyn Stark's statue
and there's this line of dialogue if you
don't remember when she gave this speech
this is from her conversation with
Talisa in season 3 episode 2 dark wings
dark words when she's talking about her
children in how badly she regrets
treating Jon Snow like crap his whole
life she talks about all the [ __ ] this
come to her family the war of the five
kings the death of Ned Stark bran
getting pushed out the window Theon
sacking Winterfell like basically the
worst possible things imaginable
happening to all of her children least
to say Sansa who was stuck in King's
Landing at the mercy of Joffrey and the
Lannisters so this is mostly a speech
teeing up Ned Stark's speech that we get
a little bit later in the teaser where
she's basically saying that I should
have loved him more like he's part of
our family even though he might be a
bastard because remember she had no idea
of his true heritage
you see Arya finally walking through the
crypts wall this Catelyn Stark voiceover
talking about Jon Snow is happening and
it really becomes more of them
foreshadowing the other stark children
learning Jon's true heritage in how it's
going to affect their familiar
relationship as Starks is he going to be
a stark of Winterfell are they gonna
treat him like a Targaryen I've already
done a couple videos talking about Arya
Stark during season eight and her
history with Jon Snow he's one of the
few other stark children that she was
close to growing up so their reunion is
obviously gonna be a really big moment
of all the Starks I think that she'll
probably be the least affected by this
big knowledge bomb that brands going to
drop on them but then they cut to John
walking past Ned Stark's statue and it's
the speech that Ned gave him before he
wrote off to the wall in season 1
episode 2 you might not have my name but
you're a stark you have my blood which
is technically true the next time we
meet we'll talk about your mother so
technically if he comes back to the
crypts of Winterfell they will probably
be talking about Lyanna stark after he
finds out so they will find a roundabout
way to pay off that moment even though
technically Ned Stark is dead he'll be
standing near his statue in the crypts
but the way they cut the speech is
they're all coming together is really
paying more reference to the lone wolf
dies the pack survives speech that we
got for all the season seven teasers
like even though we had all that Arya
Sansa drama during season seven that was
mostly meant to catalyze that lone wolf
dies pack survives so that was kind of
the thing they were trying to pay off
with their arc and obviously that's
still very important this season only
now it's more focused on Jon Snow his
heritage in the fact that they all might
die so that's sort of the way they end
the teaser there's really WTF reaction
where they turn around is if they're
seeing visions of their death like all
of their statues in the crypts so even
though we have lots of death predictions
to talk about I'm sure I'll do a video
about that sometime before the season
starts this is just HBO raising the
question like we all might die because
just as they turn around the winds of
winter blow out John's torch and then
the ice starts to cover the tropical
bird feather that was on lyanna stark's
statue obviously just teasing the coming
of the night king in his army they all
start to draw their swords john draws
Longclaw arya draws needle but you also
see the Valyrian dagger on her hip there
so she will be fighting with that but
needle is her primary weapon I would not
be surprised if they find a way to pay
off stick them with the pointy end when
she and John are sharing some scenes
together before some big battle like as
they write off you hear him say it again
don't forget stake the White Walkers
with the pointy end although technically
she'd want to stick them with the pointy
end of the Valyrian dagger but the other
big reason that you all probably
detected that we're having this
Winterfell teaser is the first big one
is because that's where the first big
battle with the night king is gonna take
place in the White Walkers now obviously
he has to wind his way down with the
army of the Dead through the last [ __ ]
in the Karstarks our IP say your
goodbyes to them if they're not all
still holed up at Winterfell
they're probably actually still people
that live up there but I think the idea
is that most of the armies are massing
at Winterfell so they're probably not
that many able-bodied soldiers left at
those castles so it's not nearly as bad
as it could be I know you're all
probably disappointed that there's no
ghost in this teaser I think they were
trying to do something that was the
least spoilery option that they had and
it's really expensive to do the special
effects for ghosts he is a part of the
season ghosts will be coming back during
season eight he's at Winterfell right
now there was a deleted scene from
season seven where Jon is leaving to go
treat with Daenerys and try to form the
Alliance where he says goodbye to ghost
they have a really nice scene they wrote
it they shot it it was all good to go
but at the last minute they had to cut
it for time they just decided not to
include it but don't worry final season
ghost one of the few direwolves
along with Nymeria that are still alive
obviously he'll be a big part of the
battle against the night king so that's
why the episodes are so big and they
spend so much money on it so that they
could pay off all those big things and
we wouldn't have to go another season
asking hey wait a minute they're up at
Winterfell walking around ghost never
leaves Jon's side where is he right now
why isn't he in frame so do not be
surprised if you see him pop up during
that next big trailer that they released
which might be February early March but
obviously there's so many other
characters so many other storylines to
pay off we'll see all that stuff when
they start dropping proper trailers so
we'll get more with Daenerys we'll learn
more about the dynamic between her and
the people at Winterfell we've already
got a little teaser for that we haven't
seen anything of Cersei the golden
company you're on Greyjoy or anyone at
King's Landing yet that'll also probably
be in that first trailer we don't really
know exactly what their marketing
campaign is gonna be like so I don't
know if they're gonna try and break this
up into different camps and release
separate teasers or if it'll just be
another proper trailer the next time we
actually get footage but the real big
news is that the premiere is happening
April 14th way earlier than I thought I
didn't think it was gonna be till like
the week after that at the earliest
because what happened is the reason why
we're getting it earlier which is great
is because they're doubling up on
episodes of true detective in probably
big little lies so I can't remember the
last time HBO did that but I think they
all sense that everybody wants the
season as fast as possible it'll be one
episode per week for six episodes just a
reminder some people are still surprised
that they're only doing six episodes
what'll happen
there'll be more promos more trailers
all kinds of EPK and footage that
they'll be dropping so I'll do videos
for everything leave all your requests
in the comments below
and what I might do is I might do a Q&A
video sometime next week for the trailer
so if you have any specific questions
that you want me to include on that just
let me know in the comments but click
here to rewatch that opening scene of
Jon's Daenerys arriving at Winterfell
from Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1
and click here for all my other Game of
Thrones season 8 promos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight